thoughts forests or accept accept that
we are a miraculous unlikely very
fragile species living in a mysteriously
oxygenated corner of a vast universe we
have never been and never will be
complete masters of our circumstances we
remain invariably at the mercy of
Awesome uncontrollable forces to which
we should submit with a measure of grace
concede concede our impotence before
events the powerlessness of our mighty
brains the humbling inflicted on us by
nature and our vulnerability to the
absurdities of microbial life let go let
go of ideals of perfection of UNCHR East
lives and flawless trajectories we
should expect regularly to be taken
wholly by surprise there is no
persecution none of it was done with us
in mind we have not been singled out we
may be victims
we were never targets love love our
fellow broken humans hold out a hand to
our similarly scared and confused
neighbors build friendships around the
always surprising and blessed discovery
of mutual vulnerability serve gain
relief from how much richer it is to
love than to be loved
and how much more gratifying to serve
than to be served take a holiday from
the grueling search for self-fulfillment
in the name of an infinitely easier goal
the reassurance and relief of other
people pessimism gain peace of mind not
by expecting the best but by scoping out
the very worst and making oneself at
peace in its grimaced recesses drain
terror of its unexamined dimensions bore
yourself out of fear appreciate
especially birdsong the drawings of the
under sevens palm trees lemons and the
memories of beaches and hugs laugh laugh
at the absurdity of this shitshow insist
on defiant humor on the way to the
gallows self forgiveness forgive
yourself for your inability to be
exactly as you would wish in as calm as
intelligent as you would hope it is
normal and in a way almost saying to be
demented quite a lot of the time small
pleasures take it one day at a time with
a special place for modest pleasures the
sight of flowers chocolate hot baths and
a few very dark jokes with your best
most unshockable friends we come from a
species that in only a few hundred
thousand years has reached a dazzling
understanding of existence has built
some stupendous machines and learnt to
think of itself as in charge we may need
to accept that we can feel in the late
hours a little bit scared and for a time
very very small
you
if you're interested in trying
psychotherapy the School of Life offers
a service by Skype around the world
click on the link for further details